i want to do something that matters
emily
you're a poet you work so hard on your
poems you want every line to be perfect
but i want the mess i want you
[Music]
this is a very dark time the violence
the suffering
that's what i want to heal with my
poetry words don't matter right now
i have so much poetry in my head with
all this conflict none of it has been
able to come out
[Music]
this family's a joke my marriage is a
lie
civil war ruins everything
this war just came out of nowhere i'm
not sure about that i think it was
pretty clear we were headed in a bad
direction
you're the only one who's brave enough
to face the truth
you know try and peddle some false hope
what if hope is all we have
[Music]
my family is in complete chaos but
nothing i do seems to be making anything
any better
you think you're fighting for something
but really you're just running away
[Music]
to be a great poet you have to feel
everything
the pleasure the pain the sunlight the
shade
yeah he just takes it a little bit too
far yes
come on now
where do you get that fire from
i can't live without you
i can't breathe without you
i want to do something that matters
don't worry everyone
emily dickinson is here to help
in the future you're actually famous
emily dickinson was the original sad
girl
[Music]
you